la question qu'est ce qu'un air de jean
luc lemoine et bertrand saint maurois
nous a rejoint alors mimi et alizée vous
connaissez les questions 4/3 ou pas du
tout je me rappelle plus ouais c'est ça
ils font toujours autant ce qui se passe
en dehors de l'émission c'est ce qui se
passe en dehors même du foie ordinaire
céder toutes les choses vous allez voir
vous allez être choqués mimie mathy je
suis radié montrer les coulisses
alizée elle connaît mais mimi avec show
quelque chose ne s'est pas reluisant
ouais alors qu'est ce qui se passe on
des premières questions
question bonjour je m'appelle michel
j'ai un gros problème
je suis très excité par gilles verdez
est ce qui pourrait être moins sexy dans
votre émission
car là je suis plus étanche
chez les femmes et je vous comprends
tout à fait michel louis gillet torride
tout le temps il cache bien son jeu le
gilou 1 il nous a fait croire quelques
semaines qu'ils pourchassent et les
pickpockets dans les transports en
commun je venais j'ai fait mon verdez
j'ai fait mon enquête
c'est faux dans le rer gilles fait du
pole dance
je vais vous révéler un secret c'est en
voyant cette photo que cyril a recruté j
ai trouvé qu'on avait pas assez de
stripteaseurs dans les villes leur style
est très vigilant sur ses chroniqueurs
avant chaque émission
ils passent nous voir pour nous dire un
petit mot d'encouragement comme ici
isabelle morini-bosc je peux tenir une
bonne routière
oui mais le moins possible moi même donc
où isabelle arrangements on se dit tous
les deux on se dit tout c'est une info à
médan dans la bouche de syrie s'est
accomplie bah oui c'est ça
il est différent de nous 1 par exemple
c'est le seul mec qui peut changer de
tête en un instant est passé du dj de
mariage un peu bourré au serial killer
attention c'est flippant
c'est tous les dons il a aussi le don de
faire vibrer son public son public
amer il ya qu'en annonçant le nom des
invités de la semaine et regardez bien
le mec derrière valérie bénaïm et on
parlait de vous deux justement et jeudi
on aura alizés qui sera avec nous qui
n'aura nous voir et qui nous dira
pourquoi voilà son compagnon a quitté
danse avec les stars parce qu'on sait
tous dans cette émission et on aura
également mimie mathy qui sera réglé
des bonbons mais après kennedy laden
appelle clos mimie mathy
et vous l'avez d'avoir toujours en
peut-être ça la map c'est pour vous qui
ont fait les gars des vues de mecs
étaient à fond derrière les c'est normal
parce que cyril est un vrai vent de
chaque soir en fin d'émission
il annonce des choses pour l'émission du
lendemain des choses qui la plupart du
temps on n'arrive jamais mais bon
l'essentiel c'est quoi c'est c'est de
les annoncer
allez
dès lors y sont méchants avait vu
numérisés franchement ils sont méchants
avec moi ils sont méchants mais est ce
vraiment étonnant
fossard que pendant les pauses thierry
jean michel discute on discutait il dise
du mal des autres ça les occupe et je
suis très flatté parce que il pas
souvent de moi à chaque agent libéral
ses textes
réponse ce n'est pas le
ce qui compte pour être heureux au
travail c'est d'avoir des vrais amis
alors ça c'est un joueur lambda le jour
des cafetières bas bizarrement
jean-michel n'a pas du tout même
discours ma place c'est normal mais je
vais pas te lasses gratuite pour ton
spectacle t1 pm et plats chauds c'est
normal mais c'est nous mêmes
évidemment que vu comme ça on pourrait
croire qu'ils me flatte car je suis en
face de lui eh bien pas du tout non pas
du tout parce que ce qui va se passer là
c'est ce qu'ils disent est un mercredi
un jour où j'étais absent à ça commence
quand steak de jean-louis pas rater ça
je crois le lac de jean-luc c'est à
paris le 20 janvier je crois on y va
tous à la première fois plusieurs fois
pourquoi plusieurs fois
la club savoir
mais il croit qu'en parlant doucement va
parler ça le mec est pervers de réponse
que siné du bien de moi je vais être
gentille c'est incroyable le problème et
il le sait c'est que j'ai pas tout les
offres de l'émission j'en ai beaucoup
mais j'ai pas tout les off donc
jean-michel n'était pas sûr que je tombe
sur son compliment mais bon comme il y'a
une solution à tout pour être sur une
touche et il en a mis portant alors là
on touche au génial
azzedine williams a commencé celle de la
one day without verra pas les
conséquences au 27 janvier les outils
marçais
surtout quand le salon est au rendez
vous on est prêt même privatiser comme
céline dion crime at ease las vegas que
lui n'y a pas de prix pour un spectacle
d'un humoriste la trempe de journée
je
mais je me ferais le spectacle jean
grenet touche avec elle mérite une
sanction pour jean-michel alors il faut
le savoir pendant les magnétos un
assistant réalisateur peut débarquer à
tout moment sur le plateau par exemple
pour demander à des chroniqueurs d'aller
enfiler un costume mais je pense qu'il
faudrait arrêter ça ferait rater ça
parce que jean michel ne vit pas bien
tout de suite le moment gênant ou un
chroniqueur pense qu'en cas d' attaque
terroriste
la première personne cible en france bat
ce sera 8 lauryn hill
président des états unis
j'espère que ça nous servira de leçon
il m'a fait peur
la tendresse que j'aime c'est correct le
public peut mourir l'ifa brat ok et
exfiltrés au débat il est grave
voilà en tout cas ça sera un homme
flatter cité pas sincère je préfère
largement les encouragements de mes
vrais amis une équipe garderie ouais
thierry est bien trop chaleureux une
session jour un spectacle les éternels
du rire a plus que deux mois à plus de
servir de personnes tu crois oui
pourquoi les chroniqueurs de tpm
belle-famille la famille des cousins de
pellicule ans
vraiment un jour lui ça fait la peine
s'appelait la pression ça j'aime pas ça
là je ne parle jamais c'est une thèse il
mais la raison il a raison mais j'ai
donc pris une grande décision pour
remplir les salles je vais te prendre en
première partie à un tu pourras faire
tenir ces mutations
quelques heures avant la rubrique quand
tu imites discrètement isabelle morini
bosc
elle a elle même dit j'ai évolué j'ai
rien mais j'ai regretté d'avoir même
date en changer
comptant des présents mais si t'es pas
libre tous les soirs on va être serré
moreau vous savez thierry moreau c-50
bac par émission dont cinquante et une
mauvaise mais ce qui est bien avec lui
c'est qu'il ne l'ait renouvelle pas ses
blagues c'est ça c'est vrai je te plait
je me mets en avion je me mets en avion
si vous la police et vous l'encouragez
prête attention
mais le mieux dans ces cas là c'est
l'indifférence mais bon vous le savez
depuis peu nabila nous a rejoint donc
thierry s'est dit qu'il avait peut-être
un nouveau public
quel regard
labinal veut vraiment se mettre bien
avec toute l'équipe
rihanna sort de quoi ils démarreront
bédéphiles dit des trucs ça me fait ch a
battu vannes on sait pas mais lui il se
dit que femme qui rit à moitié dans son
lit ouais donc il va retenter sa chance
avec de bilan et la nam il a parlé de
son smartphone mois fois mes grosses
mains ça va mais c'est que la jolie oui
bah oui ça me saoule et la peur
voilà boys par l'apple store
c'est bon ça j'étais tendresse est trop
mou en blagues sur ma vie à chaque fois
tu me fais rire
ou les
c'est clair
là on a touché au fouet
on n'est pas bien jamais vous et la
suite c'est pas beau de plus ça paraît
clair il va la pécho d'artillerie et
banon quoi parce que tu y arrives à
faire une erreur il va lui avouer
quelque chose et la décevoir car vous
allez voir s'il ya quelque chose que
nabila n'aime pas c'est le mensonge
déteste ça il se remet à 10 à chaque
fois tu ne fais
je la torture
j'ai piqué sur internet c'est pourquoi
histoire me pose des questions je
réponde ces deux mois
mais qui inquiète le rhum et demi elle
aurait on peut pas accepter ça fait
moi ça me fait peur qu'on se voit comme
ça c'est parce qu'elle est malhonnête
mais mais elle aime bien la blague de
ben dis donc c'est pas foutu c'est pas
gagné mais c'est pas foutu
à moins que d'habiles à soit très bon
public on va vérifier
alors on va vérifier avec une blague de
cyril hanouna a est ce que le patron l'a
fait autant rire que thierry moreau je
ne pense pas ça me rappelle une blague
ça me connaissez la blague ces deux jeux
qui sont d'ordre infligées herlin qui
dit à l'autre et dis moi pourquoi thé
vert et que tu as des poils et aux types
parce que je suis un kiwi qu'audard
je
j'adore ça là il adore ça les avait pas
de moi c'est vraiment de bakar combat
mais moi j'aime bien schultz et qui
s'étire un message est alors nabila a
juste un petit conseil mollo avec titi
c'est un garçon sensible
là je vais vous montrer une image c'est
gênant vous connaissez ma discrétion
cyril pas employer ce terme mais
malheureusement je retrouve pas de route
regardez bien la tête de thierry
jusqu'au bout je crois qu'il a bandé et
non j'ai fait ma belle fille
la scène
oui une femme a enfin touché mais il
était comme un fou et j'ai demandé s'il
faisait là c'est bizarre en fait je lui
explique nabila vous la selphy avec
vanessa hudgens la star de high school
music hall 1 sél fille qu'elle a eue
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle oui mais
quand tu as une bonne nouvelle qu'est ce
que tu fais battus la partage avec un
ami oui
j'ai eu ma bouton
ma moto alors vous le savez niveau vent
isabelle morini-bosc assoiffés monfils
d'éoliennes dans l'émission eh bien ça
suffit je vais lui rendre justice
aujourd'hui je voulais montrer qu'elle
avait enfin trouvé la parade pour le
public puisse prendre devant devant elle
a réussi à intéresser quelqu'un par
l'occurrence deux ex-candidats de secret
story je suis supposé délivrer une
expertise tant que des papes attend
toujours
mais j'ai mes chroniques aux médias que
tous les matins je ne
et bien là j'aime trop la cour il ya
deux semaines je vous avais montré ne
touche pas à mon poste vers sur bistro
ah oui vous en avez demandé dos alors
tout de suite un petit zapping au
ralenti assez beau
alors est ce que vous aimez crime ou pas
et oui vous êtes plutôt habilement
univers d'imagés mopo jean michel may be
je sais mon émission quand même je
préfère faites entrer l'accusé
mais c'est pas ça qu'il fallait retenir
gilbert bros et mme michaud c'est un
score de 10 à déjà je vais alors c'est
grave en france ou non mais faut surtout
pas moi en mai l'accord mais moi ça me
met très fort élections mais juste une
fois c'est pas de chaussures
les attaquants derrière parce que
thierry s'est beaucoup moqué mois dans
cette rubrique mais je voulais de
fair-play donc une question pour lui
allez c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle chrétienne j'aime
beaucoup thierry moreau que je trouve
très sexy surtout très drôle ah non je
déconne c'était juste pour passer l'été
légumes